when the browns show up for training
camp it will be a vibe that we haven't
seen in cleveland in a very long time
if ever at least not since the merger
yes there were years when the browns got
within
shouting distance of the super bowl or
whispering distance as the case may be
if you look at 1986 and 1987 two years
ago the expectations were high they were
too high and that's why i think it was
intriguing that baker mayfield said on
tuesday that
managing expectations is going to be one
of the most important things that browns
do this year yes it is because two years
ago they completely failed to manage
expectations i think the business people
with the browns in 2019 were like hey
everybody's taking it seriously let's go
make as much money as we can let's feed
this monster let's make this a big deal
and then they ended up falling flat and
even though they had a much better year
in comparison to the recent experiences
of the browns it still felt like a
disappointment and a lot of that was on
the head coach freddie kitchens for not
managing expectations now you've got
baker mayfield saying it and i assume
kevin stefanski the 2020 nfl coach of
the year will be doing it they need to
manage expectations because this thing
will get out of control the afc
is chock full of great teams it is going
to be very difficult to navigate
the likes of the bills
the patriots who will be much better the
ravens the steelers the titans the colts
the chiefs the chargers what if aaron
rodgers ends up in denver then there's
another team
that is going to be there
as
an impediment for what the browns are
trying to do could they get to the super
bowl yes
a lot of browns fans are thinking they
will put them in the nfc
and i'd say hell yeah they got a chance
to get there in the afc
that hill is a lot steeper and i think
baker mayfield has it right when he
talks about managing expectations
meanwhile videos emerged of odo beckham
jr professing that it's going to be a
special year that's the kind of thing
that cuts against
the effort to manage expectations
regardless the expectation should be
tempered by the fact that the browns are
stuck
in a great conference
and a special division one of the best
in football what if the bengals
have a trick or two up their sleeve joe
burrow healthy as of week one
you got
multiple you got all four teams it could
be potentially in the playoff
conversation and
even though theoretically all four could
make it chances are that's not going to
happen so browns first have to get to
the playoffs and then they have to worry
about these great teams that they will
come up against in january but uh good
problem to have
better than looking at your schedule
saying i don't know where the victory is
like the browns were in a couple of
years ago but the super bowl win
still may be
off in the distance somewhere this year
could be very hard to pull it off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports